our next guest kind of feels like he
should be here today is the host of the
Ross Tucker football podcast which i am
a subscriber and an avid listener and
host of the new radio.com show home and
home at 8:00 a.m. Monday through Friday
and he was at the Miami game last night
Ross we got a text from Paulie last
night be prepared to come in today and
talk about the Dolphins win it was in
the first quarter did you think at any
point that Miami was going to win that
game yeah well first of all I love that
you guys did the golden road stuff right
before I came in that's perfect timing
because that beer is delicious so I like
that secondly yeah I thought they had a
pretty good chance when I was 14 nothing
and mason rudolph was looking like
garbage I thought they had a really good
chance I mean even even when it was 14 3
and they're at midfield with a minute
and 45 left in the first half I mean
they might get into the field goal here
at worse they're gonna go into halftime
14 to 3 and then Fitzpatrick throws the
ball and it hit Nick O'Leary in a bad
spot right between the 8 and the 3 on
his chest and that was Minka Fitzpatrick
interception number one and then the
Dolphins was one of the all-time worst
calls I've ever seen sending eight guys
a full-out cover zero blitz on third and
20 with 20 seconds left with the
Steelers at the 45 when they scored the
touchdown
I can just tell you first of all I was
on the fewer sideline so I saw all the
Steelers you could just tell how much
that changed their mood going into the
locker room heard from Mike Tomlin then
I walk down the hallway in the in the
bowels of the stadium because I had
hidden three grilled chicken caprese
sandwiches for halftime and as I'm
walking down to get to my stash I walked
by the Dolphins players who are walking
to the away team locker room and it
looked like the night of the live of the
walking dead I mean you could just tell
it
I knew right then that dispute was were
going to win that game just by seeing
the emotions and body language of both
teams after that horrific and elite
remote dolphins perspective to the end
of the first half
what's the vibe down there in Miami like
do you think the GM of the Dolphins deep
down wants to win a game like that or is
the tank really on there I think that
their priority is trying to build the
team for sustained success in 2020 and
beyond I don't know that he's up there
in the skybox or wherever he is hoping
or cheering that they lose but think
about this think about all the guys
they've traded and all of the assets
they've attained and the pain they're
going through this year like what if
they beat the bangles or what if they
had beaten the Redskins a couple weeks
ago what if they don't have the number
one pick and they can't get the guy they
want I mean it just seems like a pretty
bad strategy if executed all the way
such that you're able to select the
quarterback that you want and by the way
that could even be a bigger topic I mean
they're all in presumably four to a ton
go by Aloha the guy is two for two now
in his two years as a starter in college
football in terms of having ankle
surgery I mean you're going all-in for a
guy who number one who knows you may not
be good there's about a 50/50 chance
that these guys are good but number two
McLovin is the fact that he hasn't been
able to stay healthy and either one of
his two College seasons and you're kind
of putting a lot of eggs in the basket
of a guy who's now had surgery on both
ankles in his two years of college he
still has half the season to go this
year you know during the telecast booger
mcfarland and joe testator floated that
the Dolphins might take chase young the
Ohio State defensive end and wait on a
quarterback maybe way for Trevor
Lawrence is that possible that they
would do all this tanking and not take a
QB it is possible I you know I think
perhaps that also gives them an out if
they do win a game that you know they
take a different player other than a
quarterback you know just in case I
think it probably makes sense to float
that as a possibility it's interesting
though McLovin because I know you're a
Sixers fan I'm a Sixers fan right right
so the thing about the process is that
none of the guys end up being good
Okafor stunk Noel wasn't very good
Markel folks was a disaster now they hit
on Simmons and they hit on embiid but
like an NFL team's not going to do that
first of all you know quarterbacks the
only position that has that much of an
impact like an NBA star does secondly
though you know they're not going to do
this for five years
like we're not you know we're not going
up five years of the Dolphins going oh
in 16 1 or 15 be like well - it didn't
work so now this year they're going to
go to Lawrence I mean it's just it's a
very different sport very different
situation and I feel like the hit rate
is even higher in the NBA that is in the
NFL and even our Sixers were what 50% at
best with the high picks during the
process yeah but they're the only team
in the East with a 3 or no record right
now my real quick Ross do you expect any
big names to go before 4 o'clock today
at the trade deadline yeah I think Trent
Williams is gone as soon as the team
says they're open it's raiding a guy
he's usually gone at that point and the
Browns are desperate enough that they
probably do it and I think Chris Harris
from the Broncos ends up getting moved
as well you know I think they realized
he's gone after the year might as well
try to get something good for him now if
you can those are probably the two most
likely guys in my mind although the Jets
are dealing so it sounds like Robbie
Anderson's probably as good as gone as
well okay we get ahead and break Ross
but should Paulie dress up I know you
dressed up this weekend as the guy from
Milan it was awesome
does Paulie wear a costume on Thursday
yeah well I mean is he trying to survive
in life or is he trying to thrive well
we'll learn a lot about Paulie and the
type of human being he is by whether or
not he is dressed up in a costume on
Thursday that's motivation what Paulie
oh nice foliage reports I need costumes
spicy mustard for life I'm with you
thanks Ross for more Dan Patrick show
tune in the audience channel 239 on
DirecTV stream for free on BR live or
download the Dan Patrick show app
[Music]